dude
chef inside
to be unsure
German rock superstar Udo Lindenberg is
putting himself to the test to celebrate
his upcoming 70th birthday he recorded
studio album number 36 besides uh is it
got off your age really doesn't matter
if you use now and then times are tough
and we just slog through but we have to
stick together and be stronger than time
lets it sit a music video shoot at the
hotel atlantic in hamburg judo has lived
in a suite here for two decades in the
video to his newest single budeau meets
his doppelganger his alter ego plays an
important role and a walk along the Elbe
River it's a little crazy there are two
hearts beating in my chest I'm dr.
Jekyll and mr. Hyde I'm confronting
myself safe occasion Missy's ova he
started as a drummer and then in the
1970s began writing German lyrics
stepping up to the mic to become a rock
singer one recurring theme was the
division of Germany in his 1983 song
zone dirt road not Punk oh he lamented
not being allowed to perform in East
Germany one year later East Berlin did
let him play one gig but East German
authorities canceled his planned tour
in 2008 after recovering from alcoholism
he made a comeback his album featuring
guest singer yawn delay shot up to the
top of Germany's charts
now bigger than ever Udo Lindenberg
finally had the confidence to try a
stadium tour with extravagant
performances for tens of thousands of
people it was a dream come true and
inspired a song on his new album
Google with some shows shows big
concerts that's where I feel at home
that's what I wrote about in this song
it's a declaration of love to these
fantastic audiences this cool
life on stage became his personal utopia
in London Udo went looking for material
to put on his new album Jim Jim said
let's go to London they've got a huge
Orchestra in the beetle studio the abbey
road studios Beaton's studio in every
road studio there was this huge
Orchestra
Alan zoo understood bonus to us when
this kind of voice off the streets pairs
up with a symphony orchestra that's an
unusual and spectacular combination
sometimes
the main theme to the classic film The
Godfather recorded for the first time
with German lyrics the composer's
descendants que pudo Lindenberg special
permission it's so great being here it's
a beautiful hanging over the past four
decades Udo has recorded about six
hundred songs now this album adds
another 15 to the total ina motion job
yamaha be good zoo fool i'm so happy
totally excited home of the new and i
can't wait to jump back on the stage
with my new material salud
he'll be taking the new album on the
road starting May twentieth he plans to
hit the stadium's three days after his
70th birthday no problem for you doand
and Barrett as he says a legend never
retires
you go to Titan version